you
awesome hello everyone I'm Dan I work at
a little company called magnetic here in
the city I finally made this a thing is
oh okay all right well I'll just keep
going so I'm here today to talk about
performance testing in Python a rather
performance testing and profiling in
Python and we'll see how these two
techniques plus one other that didn't
make it into the title can form a
virtuous cycle of performance
improvement so here's a little bit of
what we're going to talk about we'll
begin with a review of the types of
performance testing how to do some
profiling using the tools that are built
into the Python standard library how to
use instrumentation efficiently with in
your code and then just a quick sort of
review of how to tie all these things
together so so according to wikipedia
which is where I crypt this list from
there are four different types of
performance testing this sort of came
when I was sort of initially thinking
about this presentation came a little
bit as a surprise to me I think a lot of
us just think of sort of one thing which
we often call load test and it turns out
at least that most people are early said
I when I think of the word load tests
what I'm actually thinking of is this
thing which is according to wikipedia
sort of officially called a stress test
and so the idea of a stress test is that
you want to sort of throw a whole lot of
load at your application so suppose that
we're talking about sort of a
request-response like a web application
basically throw as much at it as we can
until we find out the point of which it
breaks so as I said I think a lot of
people confuse this with load test which
is actually a slightly different thing
so a load test is actually a
similar sort of test so you throw a lot
of low to your application but you do so
in a way that is at a sort of consistent
and controllable and expected level of
load so this might look like if I knew
that my application gets you know 1,000
requests per second then I'm going to
generate a load test which is going to
throw 1,000 requests per second at this
application and I can sort of study and
measure how it performs under those
conditions so just to sort of return to
a stress test for a second the
difference here is that it's sort of
more of an adversarial approach so in a
stress test if my load my application
usually gets a thousand requests per
second I might set up the stress test so
that I'm throwing 10,000 or 50,000
requests per second at it sort of
assuming that I can even generate that
much load so a stress test is is really
about answering the question you know
how much load can my application take
and it's really good for sort of
identifying where that breaking point is
especially if you have sort of a series
of stress tests in which you increase
the load step by step you can find out
at what point does the response time
become too slow at what point do I sort
of overwhelm a database or run out of
disk space on the machine because the
logs are too big or something of that
nature so a load test is a little bit
less of sort of an attack on your
application so what we're really trying
to answer with a load test is the
question of sort of what if so if my
normal production load is a thousand
maybe I'll run a load test just with a
constant load of two thousand requests
per second let's see what happens at
that level it's really good for things
like capacity planning so if I'm you
know releasing a new version of my code
I want to see normal production load as
a thousand can i still stand up to that
with this new version of the code how
many servers do I need to run in order
to support this many requests per second
and so on so the third type according to
wikipedia is something that they call a
spike tests again this is very sort of
similar to the previous to the major
difference here is that unlike in a
stress test in a load test in a spike
test you have sort of a constant level
of load and then it
suddenly increases and suddenly is
really important here it's not sort of a
gradual ramp up over time this is to
simulate something like you know if my
blog was on the front page of hacker
news which actually happened to me then
you know you're suddenly going to go
from getting maybe a few requests per
second to hundreds of thousands of
requests per second so what sort of
happens under those situations this is
also good for sort of simulating what
might happen if you had some sort of
production incident maybe half of your
web servers went down and the remaining
half had to handle twice as much load
very suddenly or some sort of deployment
bug maybe you realize halfway through a
rollout that half of your servers aren't
answering requests at all something like
that and the question that we're really
trying to answer here is is my my code
or really more my application as a whole
is it adaptable can it stand up to this
amount of load and sudden changes in the
load and finally there's there's one
more type of performance testing called
a soak test and the difference here is
that a soak test will typically run for
much longer than any of the other three
types of tests that we've been talking
about so here you might run it for hours
days or even weeks if you sort of have
the hardware and the ability to do that
and the question that we're trying to
answer here is is you know what happens
over a longer period of time do I run
out of file handles do I run out of disk
space stuff like that so a magnetic we
run a really high volume web platform
that's dealing with hundreds of
thousands of requests per second 24
hours a day solo testing is really
important to us and or sorry i should
say performance testing is very
important to us and we've sort of
developed internally a couple of best
practices about how to implement it
effectively so i think number one is is
that in order to get sort of reliable
results in the ability to interpret the
results from your performance tests it's
very important to isolate your
performance test from as many external
influences as you can so for us what
this means is that we actually have a
dedicated
performance testing environment that has
copies of many of the production
components so databases web servers all
the different sort of bits of plumbing
that they all connect together with this
is obviously very expensive hello this
is fairly expensive but it actually pays
off because we're running this service
that has to be on 24 7 it's very
important for us to be able to study and
understand what happens under different
scenarios if you're in a situation or if
you're in a hosting provider something
like Amazon this can actually be fairly
cheap especially if you combine it with
something like chef puppet ansible etc
for configuration management you might
be able to just sort of spin up this
environment very easily run a test for
an hour or two and then spin it down you
don't have to pay very much for it one
other thing that's worth noting here is
that at magnetic and sort of in general
this performance testing environment
doesn't need to be as big or as capable
or as have as many machines in it as
your production environment does so what
we do is let's see our performance
testing environment is about one
twentieth the size of our production
environment so we know both from
experience and from how we've designed
it that if we run say a load test or a
stress test that we can basically
multiply that number by 20 and that
tells us what our capacity in production
is so the second sort of really
important best practice I actually
should put this one first is that it's
really important to be very consistent
in the way that you generate loading
your performance testing environment so
like any other sort of testing like unit
testing like integration testing if you
can't sort of reproduce it it's not
really going to tell you very much about
your application or about your platform
or how components work well together so
there's a really easy win here and this
is in fact what we actually do it
magnetic we take logs out of production
and we just replay those into our
performance testing environment
once we have this sort of repeatable
testing then that lets us really
experiment with okay if I tweak this
setting or if I rewrite this bit of code
or if I stop calling that bit of code
what does that actually do to our
overall performance profile this is a
really valuable way to without a lot of
risk and without having to invest a lot
of time to be able to sort of begin a
cycle of continuous improvement into in
your performance of your application
okay so next up the next sort of tool in
our tool belt is profiling in Python it
turns out that this is pretty easy sort
of following along with the Python sort
of mantra batteries included in the
standard library there's a couple of
different modules that let you do
profiling in a couple one module which
lets you sort of understand and
interpret the results of your profiling
runs so for what I suspect or historical
reasons and I haven't actually sort of
study this in detail there's two
different profiling modules one is named
profile one is named see profile
basically you should just always use see
profile it does the same things it has
the same API and it's just a little bit
faster and then there's a third module
called P stats which lets you sort of
interpret the results and we'll take a
look at this in a second however
unfortunately and also like much of the
see the Python standard library the
documentation for these guys is not
really included so I'm actually going to
do a little demo in a moment and finally
the API for these things is really just
really really terrible and the best way
to use it is sort of hidden within the
documentation so avoid run avoid run ctx
they're no good and they won't tell you
anything useful about your code instead
what you should do is something that
looks like this so what we're doing here
is we're importing the see profile
module creating a profile object which
is the guy that's actually going to
begin collecting data about what
function calls our code is making when
each of them begins when each of them
ends which
course then tells us how long each of
them took and this lets you sort of
enable and disable the profiler to cover
specific sections of your code that you
might care about this is by far the most
flexible way to work with the profiles
profilers that are in the standard
library every time you call enable and
disable in a pair like this it's going
to sort of accumulate results from
within those sections back into this
profile object so you can actually just
sort of analyze specific sections of
your code and ignore all of the other
stuff that you might not be interested
in the standard library doesn't give
this to you in something like a context
manager or a decorator or at least as of
2.7 it doesn't but it's really simple to
turn this into one of those two things
and there's lots of examples on the
Internet of people doing exactly that oh
I just want to show one last thing here
or point out one last thing so after you
sort of run all of these different
sections of your code under profiling
you want to call this dump stats
function which is going to basically
save out all of that data into a file
that you can then analyze later and how
you do that is using the piece that's
module and and using it looks something
like this so there's a lot that you can
do with p stats and I want to actually
show more than I could sort of fit on
two slides in any reasonable way so
let's see if excellent it worked okay so
this is about the most simple or very
close to the most simple hello world web
app that you can write here i'm using
bottle the actual framework that i'm
using is sort of irrelevant and
uninteresting so there's a single
handler in this web app called / hello
and if you pass it a name in a query
string then it's going to say hello to
that name otherwise it'll say hello
world down at the bottom in the if name
equals main section you can see that
little recipe where I'm setting up the
profiler enabling it running my
application and then because of the way
that bottle works I have to kill it with
ctrl C so I'm
using a finally block to disable and
save the output this is actually going
to be kind of challenging to type and
hold the mic at the same time Oh that'd
be awesome this is very strange because
I can't find my mouse where is it there
it is okay so i have this file here URLs
text which just contains a whole bunch
of calls this function that we were just
looking at so what i'm going to do is
just run this a bunch of times after i
start my app
actually work it really good okay by
getting really close to things so that's
why I came up here on stage
okay so that's probably enough so I'm
just going to kill the app in the
finally block we remember that it saved
out this file a proof move it up a bit
okay so import p stats stats is P stats
stats to which we pass the file name
which was apt proof so let's just take a
basic look at what this looks like we
get out of stats so if we call print
stats it's basically just going to print
out a whole bunch of stuff so the first
thing that will notice about this this
was obviously a very short sort of
profiling run if you run this in in a
program that's running for even a couple
of minutes let alone hours or a much
bigger program you're going to have a
lot of stuff here so we need some way to
sort of make sense of this effectively
so the first and most immediate thing
that you should always sort of remember
is that print stats takes an argument
which will limit sort of how much it
prints out so let's just take a look at
15 rows of results that's just about
perfect um so we can see that the
columns here on the left are the number
of calls the total time the perk
all-time the cumulative time and the I
think it's actually the cumulative
cumulative per call time for each of the
rows and what each of the rows is is the
sort of aggregate information about the
invocation of some particular function
or method in this program this we only
ran a couple of requests through so the
numbers here are mostly 0 if you're
running it on something that's doing on
an application that's doing something
more interesting than just saying hello
world you'll start to see you know
bigger numbers in some places and
smaller numbers in other places this is
going to sort of help guide your your
exploration basically of this profile
and that's going to sort of inform where
you want to spend your time optimizing
your code investigating why something
might be slow etc so when you just
create the stats object it sort of
initially begins life in this sort of
unordered uninitialized state but
fortunately we're able to sort of sort
and interact with this so let's
call before we print the stats will do
sort nope sort stats and in this case
we'll just sort by maybe the number of
calls and then print the top 15 so here
we can see that in this run we had for
certain methods something on the order
of 30,000 calls I may think I made maybe
a total of 1,500 or 2,000 request to
this application something like that so
we can immediately see that somewhere in
here something is going on it's calling
these things sort of an awful lot of
times Len is is often in profiling
results you know one of the top
offenders it sort of depends on what the
code is doing obviously just a brief
aside these things that show up in the
little curly braces are basically built
in functions or things that are
implemented in C and things that show up
as path a colon line number parentheses
function name those are functions that
are defined as pure python functions so
if I wanted to see you know what this f
get function is doing I could just open
up that file and go to that line number
okay so a few other things that are
interesting to know and this is going to
sort of come back to that point I made
earlier about the horrible ugly API
which is not at all documented is that
you can sort by multiple things here so
what would be a good second thing to
sort by maybe cumulative well actually
that's going to be the same order about
per call p see the set of values that
are accepted here in to sort stats are
an arbitrary set of about thirty
thirty-five or forty abbreviations of
the names of those four columns I don't
know where that came from there's
literally a function in this object
which will sort of tell you what all of
the valid things are but
what they actually sort by you just have
to sort of experiment and play around
with it usually you can just go with the
column names that'll get you something
like what you want but not all the
column names are actually accepted as
things that you can sort by I don't know
why this is the case it's kind of
horrible but if you do this enough
you'll just sort of learn which one's
work and which ones don't and get on
with your life okay so that didn't
actually really show anything different
in the display just based on what this
profiling data was but you can actually
give it multiple arguments and it will
sort by those things in the way in the
way that you expect finally in the print
stats function if I want to just look at
let's say I want to sort of ignore all
of the stuff that's in the standard
library and I want to just focus on the
stuff that's in my application you can
pass in strings here which will
basically act as filters against the
against the the name column so the
rightmost column so if I put in here a
pie which was the name of the Python
module that this app was defined in then
in this case it's actually only going to
print out one thing because there's only
one function in that module but you can
imagine if you had a bigger more
complicated program that you would be
able to use this to sort of filter based
on that stuff just to give a more
complete example if I wanted to show
only the things that were built in
functions or things implemented and see
I can filter just by curly brace and
that's going to show me all the things
that basically contain a curly brace
somewhere in that name call so this is a
pretty good start there's a few more
things that I that I think are really
valuable ways to explore and experiment
with your profiling that are not shown
in any obvious way in the documentation
they are mentioned there and that's two
functions one is called print callers
and print collies so they do sort of
what you would expect from the name so
if I wanted to find out who is actually
calling the Len function this many times
then rather than saying print stats i
would say print callers of when
and if i zoom out a little will actually
be able to see where many of these
things are coming from so here's
basically every function within this
application or within this profile run
that called Len at some point and we can
see here it's sort of broken out by each
caller how many times it was called the
total time and the cumulative time of
Len for each of those calls coming from
each of those places this is maybe not
the most exciting example if this
function we're doing something more
interesting than Len does you might see
that we call it from some places and it
takes much longer than when we call it
from other places there's also print
collies which basically does the
opposite of this so if I want to find a
rather look at the profiling results
from everything that my hello method
called i can say print call please of
hello and this is going to show me you
know the things that are sort of direct
calls from here which was query string
template and parse QSR so James ask can
you create a call graph from this
question should wait for the end please
okay so there there are some tools that
I'm not very familiar with and I sort of
prefer life in a text world I think run
snake run is the sort of common one that
people use it's not exactly a call graph
but it shows you sort of a tree map
display of sort of the timing and to a
certain extent the call tree I assume
that there's enough information here to
create a call graph I just don't know if
the top my head of any tools that do
that okay so I'm running a little bit
behind I'm going to speed up here no I
go back
great okay so we just walked through
sort of what profiling actually looks
like just to sort of take a brief
retrospective on what we looked at
profiling is going to really tell us
where something is slow it's not
necessarily going to answer the question
of why that thing is slow that's still
sort of left as an exercise to the
reader but it is going to help us
identify you know let's say that we ran
a load test and we found that our
application after making some changes is
half as fast as it used to be if we run
a profiling run against sort of the
previous and the current version by
experimenting with an exploring through
the profile data will be able to find
out which parts of it have slowed down
so like with all the other sorts of
performance testing that we've looked at
repeatability is really important we
actually use the same performance
testing environment basically plus a
feature flag in our application to
trigger profiling at magnetic this is
proved to be sort of a really valuable
way of making this very easy and very
useful for developers so we have sort of
a one click run you can set up a branch
of your code sort of run a a profile
test or a stress test and then get back
the results are test take about 40
minutes to an hour so there are a couple
of other profilers that I don't have
time to demo but I will just briefly
mention so line profile profiler as the
name suggests will give you sort of line
by line timing information of code
within a single function it works
basically with a decorator around that
function or there's a different way to
call it you run that a couple of times
then it'll tell you this line was
executed a hundred times and it took
over those hundred times you know this
many milliseconds or this many
microseconds if you sort of identified
that a single function is slow but you
can't figure out why that's a good way
to go there's also an alternative
profile are called yeah p which is an
acronym for yet another
python profiling something I don't know
what the I stands for and the only
reason that I bring it up here and it's
actually an important one is that the
standard library profilers do not sort
of handle threads well so if you have
threads in your program when the main
thread pauses during profiling the way
that that's going to show up is just
that that function call sort of took
longer than it then it really did so
what ya p does is basically when the
thread switches to another thread it
sort of takes note of that and subtracts
the time that another thread was
executing from the time that it's
recording for whatever function it's
profiling yeah p also collects profiling
results sort of across all different
threads which can be helpful or maybe
not depending on what you're trying to
do okay so the the sort of third
ingredient in our virtuous cycle is
instrumentation instrumentation can mean
lots of been things lots of different
people so here's what I mean by it I
mean putting extra code into your
application that records things like how
frequently something was called and how
long it took when you're recalling it so
this is obviously a little bit similar
to profiling the difference is that
instrumentation libraries are typically
designed to be relatively low overhead
or very low overhead so you can actually
leave them on while your application is
running a production so what we use a
magnetic and it works really well for us
I recommend it to people who are doing
web application types things is stats d
we actually use sort of a variant of
stats d called data dog which adds a
little bit of extra ability to sort of
slice and dice your data as well as a
nice web interface to sort of you what
that looks like I'm behind but i will
show you a brief example of that or not
because my browser won't work but let's
see so what we collect is is basically
these two types of time series metrics
so one is counters how many times did we
request of type X and the other our
timers how long did requests of type X
take so what we do is we'll basically
just have these graphs up and visible in
our office all the time you sort of get
a feel for what looks like normal on
particular days of the week or times the
day and you can sort of quickly notice
visually notice when something is out of
the ordinary data dog also lets you
define alerts about that so if metric X
Y is greater than a certain value send
us an alert as an email it goes to our
on-call rotation it's really nice and
just to show how easy it is to use this
is a literally code that would actually
work so there's the stastny module and
it defines a couple of functions the
timed function works as a decorator the
increment function creates that counter
series and it will just increment that
value by whatever the number of
arguments is this is where I would show
you data dog okay so finally so the
virtuous cycles so this is what we've
sort of been building to and what I've
been talking about for the past 30
minutes basically goes like this so we
begin by sort of adding this
instrumentation and alerting into our
code this will basically tell us when
something has gone wrong or when
something is out of the ordinary when
that happens we have this automated
repeatable performance testing
environment in which we can run a test
that will help us sort of zero in on
perhaps you know what service is causing
trouble or perhaps what part of that is
causing trouble once we've narrowed it
down a little bit we use profiling to
identify the sort of particular part of
the code that is performing slowly or
that is having some sort of scalability
issue and that lets us then sort of
focus our optimization on just that part
sonu famously said that premature
optimization is the root of all evil
this is the way to know that you're not
optimizing prematurely thanks everyone
yeah any questions so the question is in
the profiling example I showed the
cumulative time and the time was all 0
yes so the I guess the the unit here is
like 1000 of the second yes so so these
are the time columns are in seconds so
the the resolution here is basically
milliseconds so because it is zero when
you actually sorted it it does not do
anything just because it's 0 can we
actually change the unit here to go
further like one millionth of a second
or something yeah that's a good question
if there were documentation with the
module I would be able to give you a
firm answer there might be but I'd have
to actually like read the code to find
out I assume that the timing is sword is
sort of float seconds and so there is
more resolution and you could probably
customize it to to show you what you
wanted to but I don't think there's a
default option to do that can you tell
us more about data down and what it does
for you yeah I can so I didn't mean this
to be a sales pitch but um I think the
best way to do this might be
no it's it's in the full screen thing
hold on one sec
so this is an example of the sort of
charting that data dog gives you so this
is from earlier today actual data from
our actual application the details of
this aren't necessarily very interesting
or important until you understand what
our application does but just to give
you sort of a brief overview on the top
left most chart we're showing the number
of bids which is basically how often we
try to buy and add an online ad on the
top right we're seeing how often we've
actually won the color codings here are
basically from which of our partners
we've actually bought this at or tried
to buy this ad so by themselves that's
actually very useful data for us if we
see that sort of suddenly go up or
suddenly go down that tells us something
about what's going on in production
right now one of the things that's
really nice about data dog is that you
can actually combine these things so in
this chart down here we're charting
rates which is basically the ratio of
the top two charts so we can see that
we're winning on average about fifteen
percent of what we try to buy which is
sort of par for the course for us if
that suddenly went up or suddenly went
down again we would be able to see you
know something had gone wrong and then
just to sort of show another example
this is a timing chart from one of those
stats Dita timed calls which is telling
us that our 95th percentile response
time is seven milliseconds and our
meeting response time is 3.3
milliseconds so some of the other things
that data gives you is a way to sort of
set up a whole bunch of alerts about all
of these different metrics they're very
cheap to collect so we have many
hundreds of them throughout our
application you can see that some of
them are actually alerting right now I
should probably go and fix that but many
of them are okay and that's sort of what
we like to see and that's very good for
each of these alerts you can customize
who they go to whether or not they go to
page or duty which will learn on-call
rotation etc is that sort of what you
were looking for cool anyone else yeah
so the question was about graphite night
in catches annular carbon so I've
actually never used those myself my
understanding is that they offer a lot
of the same sorts of things as data dog
does data dog is nice because I don't
have to run it these guys are a company
you know we pay them and they run all
this for us and it's just one last thing
that I have to deal with I think it
offers sort of very similar sorts of
capabilities and I that's certainly an
option that that people should look at
if you're not either willing or able to
work with a vendor for this sort of
stuff oh one more of here so you did
briefly touch on when you design your
performance testing environment that you
try to scale it to like 120th size how
do you go about ensuring that that
always gives you valid results I mean
you were talking about sort of voodoo
magic of comparing it to what we see in
production and well it looks like it's
good enough so we assume it's fine
basically but do you ever actually try
to do any sort of sort of empirical data
to actually make sure that that actually
matches up yeah I'm actually really glad
you brought that up so that's one of the
other things that instrumentation makes
really easy is that we have the same
instrumentation in the performance
testing environment as well as in
production so we can actually do that
sort of apples to apples comparison in
our case we cheat a little bit we know
that it's about one-twentieth because
our cluster is 20 machines in production
and one machine with the same
configuration in the performance testing
environment so it's a little bit easier
to do the math there and the application
sort of makes it work that way but
without it we could still use these sort
of timing metrics and performance
metrics to sort of extrapolate and at
least guess what that factor is okay um
yeah that's that certainly is that
certainly could be an issue so the
question was you know Arthur bottlenecks
that only show up at scale yeah and and
those are things
that you know you still do sort of need
to use your brain and think about your
architecture in your application to
understand where those things are and
how they might impact your performance
tests all right thanks everyone